JENNY BROWN: Critter
Junction has been scaling,
and their database model
is reaching its limits.
Let's look at how we helped
Critter Junction better serve
their users by doing a
bit of rearchitecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Building a flexible, scalable
database architecture
for a large multiplayer gaming
application is no easy task.
The larger a platform is
and the more components that
have to interact
with each other,
the more tech
problems can arise.
Some of the problems
that Critter Junction had
to face for their
flagship multiplayer game
included handling
global consistency,
importing data, batch
processing for analytics,
and event streaming.
On top of that, this system
had to handle access spikes.
That after-work rush of
users logging on is no joke,
and downtime is not an option.
Such a complex problem couldn't
be solved with just one tool.
And because Critter
Junction had already
broken their application
into microservices,
this allowed them to apply
the appropriate tools
to each component as needed.
Yup, that means mixing and
matching Google Cloud database
options, based on questions
like what latency is required?
How much persistent data
needs to be supported?
Does it require
offline reporting?
Is the data structured
or unstructured?
Like we covered last
episode, Critter Junction
chose Firestore for
their spinoff minigame,
but it's also a natural
fit for problems
that need a scalable
cloud database
with real-time synchronization
and offline support,
like their flagship game.
And with automatic
scaling up to 1
million concurrent connections
and 10,000 writes per second,
Critter Junction doesn't
have to lift a finger
or be concerned with downtime,
regardless of usage spikes.
This means Critter
Junction's architecture
could use Firestore for the
game's front-end services,
like player authorization
and profiles,
to store billions of documents
with hierarchical world-state
data.
To take care of
the game inventory
and other game elements that
need global consistency,
like purchase history,
Critter Junction
uses Spanner as their
main game database.
Since Spanner is a fully
managed relational database
that offers unlimited
scalability,
strong consistency, and
five nines availability,
Spanner provides a globally
consistent database
that can track up to petabytes
of all these important details
without being a choke point
in their architecture.
Spanner supports Critter
Junction's usage spikes
without planning
or downtime, which
is a relief for data
admins and users alike.
And as you can imagine,
Critter Junction's game
accesses some data
sets more than others--
leaderboards and player
profiles, to name a few.
To prevent lag in the UI
and maintain a quality user
experience for this
frequently used data,
Critter Junction went
with Memorystore,
a fully managed
service that uses
Redis to store
in-memory data, creating
a regional in-memory cache
that speeds up access
to that frequently
queried data and improves
scale and performance
as demand grows.
With Memorystore for
Redis, Critter Junction
was able to start
small and increase
the size of their
instances without downtime
by monitoring usage traffic
and simply using the GCP
console to make adjustments.
For Critter Junction's
huge analytical workload
and time series data--
that's where Bigtable fits in.
It flips scaling on its head and
focuses on connection latency.
While traditional
NoSQL databases often
restrict elastic scalability
with high management overhead,
Bigtable gave Critter Junction
consistent sub-10-millisecond
latency while scaling to match
storage needs, with no downtime
during reconfiguration.
And because Critter
Junction's game events
were logged into Bigtable,
their support experts
could troubleshoot
problems directly.
From there, Critter Junction
needed a SQL-friendly solution
to analyze player profile
and back-end data.
So they used BigQuery, a
highly scalable, serverless,
multicloud data warehouse.
BigQuery scalability
comes from the vast number
of multitenant resources
deployed under the hood,
allowing them to
instantly allocate
large chunks for seconds at
a time while only billing you
for what you use,
to keep costs down.
Critter Junction
periodically updates
BigQuery with front-end
and back-end data, which
is then run through
data analytics pipelines
to identify gameplay mechanics
that need improvements.
So there we have it.
Critter Junction used
Firestore as a document
store for their
front-end services
and real-time game data,
Spanner for real-time play data
and purchases, and Memorystore
to cache common fetches.
Then Bigtable ingests
game event logs
while BigQuery helps their
analytics team aggregate data
from all those sources.
Keep in mind, this
is just one example
of how to build a heterogeneous
storage and analytics
architecture that can
span any industry.
And while developing a
database architecture that
supports tens of thousands of
concurrent players isn't easy,
it is possible.
So stay tuned to learn how
Critter Junction continues
to improve the design of
their database architecture.
For more on this
example architecture,
check out the description below
and check out our other series
on databases below.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]